I gotta ask you in the years past
astrology was always something that you
found at the back of a magazine it was a
little four or five sentences this is
what your day or your week or your month
is gonna look like what's changed well
so the appetite from our audience for
astrology content is huge our traffic to
astrology content online has increased a
hundred and twenty eight percent
year-over-year 74 percent of my readers
have told me that they are quote
obsessed with astrology 74 percent II 4
percent and 72 percent check their
horoscope every day so when I took over
the magazine I knew that the single page
of monthly horoscopes that traditional
women's magazines have done for
millennia just wouldn't cut it any more
and so what I did is I introduced a 9
page section every month to our magazine
it's dedicated entirely to astrology
that's 10% of our magazine we're just
seeing a ton of success and an interest
here was the interest in astrology
always there or is it just now in 2019
that they're just a lot of Millennials
including your reader 74% one of the
beauties of Cosmo is that we reach so
many people of varying ages and
demographics we reach 81 million readers
every month most of whom are Millennials
but there are a lot of Millennials moms
and Millennials aunts and sisters and
friends and they have always been
interested in astrology it's just that
for the younger generations they feel
more value in it they perceive more
value in astrology and there are a
couple of reasons the first is that
Millennials self-report more stress and
less certainty about their future than
any generation before them they're also
less religious than any generation
before them so they are looking for
guidance and they are looking for
structure I think one of the
misconceptions about Millennials and
astrology is that they're using it
mostly as a predictive tool which they
certainly are that's part of the value
it's part of the fun and the social
cachet when we can all sort of
collectively moan about mercury going
retrograde but the real value is insight
into ourselves how we work why
we work how other people around us work
and so we're looking for a shorthand
that helps us understand the world
around us quickly and if I know that
you're a Sagittarius I know before we
even sit down together that you're
fun-loving and adventurous and that you
like to read and I know what I can ask
you about what's on your nightstand
right now you know you got it
even before I there's gonna be my last
question I told you I told you what I'm
probably blushing right now also you yep
that's me I I'd like to think I am Wow
so did this knowledge the skill that you
had this talent did that come from your
readers saying to you that look we want
more of this stuff or you clearly I
think predated what Millennials are into
I mean I'm an intuitive person and I
have a good gut instinct I think you
have to in order to be an editor of a
media brand like this one in this day
and age I was not an astrology expert I
have learned from my audience and their
interest has led us to report things
that we didn't know before and so my
entire team we've all become astrology
experts even though we didn't
necessarily intend to what is your
research shown as far as how people are
using astrology I mean you pointed a
little bit to the fact that there's a
lot more stress times are uncertain
right now for a lot of people in this
country and around the world and they're
looking for something they're looking
for something that gives them some
insight into who they are what have you
seen or what have you learned as to what
people may be gaining from astrology I
think they get a peace of mind the the
kind of the kind of peace that previous
generations might have gotten from going
to church I think a young woman now can
get from reading a very in-depth
horoscope that helps her sort of situate
herself you know empowered young women
face a world that
might not be ready for them to be as
empowered as they are and so it's
helpful to understand the landscape that
you're walking into and I think that's a
great sense of of peace for this
generation which is as you say very
stressed the misconceptions or the
preconceived notions that people may
have about astrology I think they think
it's sort of like a crystal ball sort of
like a psychic tool which isn't really
the way it works one of our astrologers
and our in our recent issue compared
astrology to a clock a clock is not the
reason that it's 9:00 p.m. but it helps
you see and understand that it's 9:00
p.m. and that's what astrology is that's
how astrology works it simply explains
when the planets are in this position
and have been in this position in the
past this is what's happened
consistently as a result so what might
happen is this you know and when I was
in that meeting your editorial meeting
one of the things I realized is I don't
know if it's the way it was marketed or
the way that because it was in the back
of the checkout counter magazine that we
saw basically people's Sun signs and
that gave us a little bit of insight
into perhaps who they are and their
personality but that it's just a lot
more complicated than that and maybe
that's why people don't see it as an
actual science yes
right they think well the monthly
horoscope it's not totally accurate to
me it's because you're so much more than
your Sun sign Sagittarius doesn't
explain the whole universe that makes up
who you are as a person so one of our
astrologers ELISA Kelly has an amazing
way of explaining your Sun Moon and
rising signs and why they matter those
are the three most important signs and
the deal is your rising sign is the path
that you're on in life it's the road
that you follow I'm a rising Sagittarius
which makes me adventurous and
innovative and I need to move forward
and explore your Sun side your
Sagittarius I'm a Sun Virgo that's the
car that you're in on that road it's the
structure within which you move forward
I'm a Virgo so I'm obsessive about
detail I'm a perfectionist and your moon
sign
that reflects your inner life and so
your moon sign is what's driving the car
I'm a moon Libra which means I really
care that everyone around to me is happy
and healthy and taken care of I want
everybody in the car to be cool with
where we're going and why we're going
there so if that's really the full
picture in astrological terms of who you
are
that's really cool a lot of people will
say I'm on I'm born on the cusp I'm on
the last day or the first day of a sign
and that matters and where would that
come from if it's not a thing you're
saying it's not a thing
I know astrological thinking now is that
cusps aren't really real there is a
certain day on which everything shifts
into a new mode so that's what our
astrologers tell us and they're the
expert what if I was born on a leap year
and December 21st is not Sagittarius
December 21st is Capricorn I mean what
you're doing at cosmopolitan does
dovetail with the magazine's history and
the content that you've always provided
your readers yes we've done book Aziz
ins we've done books on astrology so
this is certainly not far afield for us
it's right in our wheelhouse and the
interesting thing at this time is that
again young women really care about it
and my magazine will always follow what
young women really care about it doesn't
seem as if men are is interested in it I
must be an aberration maybe because I
massage I'm a rising sad so you know I
identify with you you know we do see
that men are less interested in
astrology because they're less inclined
to believe that it's quote real or
perhaps the issue is that they're more
fixated on whether it is real I don't
think that women necessarily think it
has to be scientifically proven in order
to be a viable tool to help them make
decisions or to help them understand
themselves more deeply which is such an
important thing for Millennials is is
that the path to success for them comes
through understanding themselves and so
more and more men are coming along I
think especially as my reader is asking
her tinder date what his birth chart is
so she can go see if they're compatible
I think
or younger generations of men will get
more into astrology are you seeing a
demand for more than you even can put
into the magazine oh of course there is
basically more interest in this content
than we even have time to produce it but
we're putting it everywhere and
everywhere we put it it works do you
think that people use astrology to make
really big life decisions I do I think
it's a helpful tool and I also think
when you're a woman in this world you
want a lot of perspectives and you want
to consult a lot of viewpoints and make
an educated informed decision based on
all the information that you're
collecting so to me it's sort of an
additional data set do you find that
people let me ask you this do you find
that that the interest for your readers
cuts across demographics it cuts across
Melissa tea yeah everybody's into
everybody's into it and it really is
it's a communication tool when you say
Mercury's in retrograde you hear a
collective groan and everybody gets it
right it's a way to bond with people and
it's just fun yeah that's incredible
that's good this is so much fun this is
so interesting Wow